вже немає сумніву що третій рік війни
буде складнішим за попередні два і це
Гірка правда життя якою треба навчитися
розмовляти з власним народом і вона
далека від солодкої брехні телемарафону
на кшталт кави в Ялті
і влітку завершення
війни солодка брехня повністю демотивує
український народ і перешкоджає
мобілізації Я Хочу
наголосити що керівництво парламенту має
негайно скасувати заборону на трансляції
засідання Верховної Ради заборону на
трансляції засідань погоджувальної ради
і запустити журналістів
фоє кого ви
боїтеся українського народу
ні ви боїтеся
Правди керівництво парламенту має
скасувати огідні і незаконні
розпорядження про блокування виїзду
депутатів і формування делегацій
постійних міжпарламентських об'єднань
тому що це кримінальний злочин
перешкоджання міжпарламентської
дипломатії а
самодурство ніколи не переможе диплома
дипломатія
переможе позиція нашої
фракції Не повторювати помилки які
виробили перед війною коли ви півроку не
ставили на
голосування наші законопроекти по
укріпленння обороноздатності і
збільшення фінансування армії Зараз ми
вимагаємо негайно поставити і розглянути
перше законопроект Про п'яту колону
Росії Московську церкву
друге треба негайно припинити спробу
зіткнути військове і військовополітичне
керівництво держави і для цього
розглянути законопроект Про погодження з
головнокомандуючим призначення та
звільнення командувачів він несе за це
відповідальність а можливості впливу
немає ніякого ми
вимагаємо спростити процедуру надання
убд ми вимагаємо 30% ПДФО бригад
повернути на рахунки бригад ми вимагаємо
створити ТСК про фортифікаційні споруди
бо не будівництво є злочин ми вимагаємо
щоби російську Ду російську думу не
порівнювати з Верховною Радою України
весь перелік поставте на голосування
Слава
Україні